Okay,
here I go. Been getting some,
like, around the eye dryness.
I don't really know what's going on with allergies.
Let me see. Take your hand away.
I don't know what's going on here,
but I was looking it up,
and they said one of the best remedies for this type of
hydritis is plain yogurt.
Haha. And I said to myself,
well, jeez,
I've got a batch, like,
fresh off the oven, like,
so here we go.
This is.
This is my Greek yogurt batch that I've been Greek
I. You can see I've actually had quite a bit of runoff.
So that's the difference between normal yogurt and Greek yogurt
is you're just training off some of the way.
So there it is.
And I said, she'll use that some over baking.
Um. So here I go.
I mean, I don't really. Yeah,
this is my first time putting yogurt on my face,
but
it was pretty good.
Yeah, just put it all around the eye.
Oh, yeah, I think this was a good idea.
It was in the refrigerator,
so it's like, super.
It's kind of hot outside today,
so this feels pretty good.
I
feel better already.